I'm very happy to be joining you
virtually at the stoical on X Brisbane
conference for 2019 largely focused on
Epictetus so I took as the title and
subject for this talk one really key
idea and practice of Epictetus that's at
the core of stoic philosophy that is
keeping one's proi racist
in accordance with nature and I'm gonna
talk about a few different things in
this a bit of history what exactly is
this thing Pride racists that we're
mentioning what does in accordance with
nature mean gonna give you a few
examples from common life and that
Epictetus himself
brings up and then talk about what it
what it really means to keep our prior
ASIS in accordance with nature by using
our Faculty of prior ASIS the Faculty of
choice to work on itself before that
though let's let's actually take a look
at one of the key passages where this
arises this is in chapter 4 of the
enchiridion I've got the Loeb Edition
here so it's a little bit old timey
translation it's old father so and it
runs like this when you are on the point
of putting your hand to some undertaking
remind yourself what the nature of that
undertaking is if you're going out of
the house to bathe put before your mind
what happens at a public bath those who
splash you with water
those who jostle against you those who
vilify you and rob you and thus you will
set about your undertaking more securely
if at the outset you say to yourself I
want to take a bath and at the same time
to keep my moral purpose prior ASIS in
accordance with nature and do so in
every undertaking for thus if anything
happens to hinder you and your bathing
you'll be ready to say oh well this was
not the only thing that I wanted but I
wanted to keep my moral purpose in
harmony with nature and I shall not so
keep it if I am VAX at what is
going on now we don't go to public baths
all that often but we can practice this
in so many other circumstances and we've
got two key ideas here we've got that a
moral purpose which is the translation
here for prior ASIS and we've got this
in harmony with nature or in accordance
with nature and both of these are our
central concepts in stoic philosophy the
one more in Epictetus and the one
running throughout the entire stoic
tradition I think that both of these
terms require a little bit of
examination or analysis but for
different reasons when it comes to this
term Pro Race is this Greek term right
there's no perfect translation for it
and we might be tempted to you know shy
away from it a bit in part because it
seems too difficult we have to be on
guard against getting it wrong and miss
translating it and here are some of the
translations Faculty of choice moral
purpose will state of character moral
character mind volition these are all
different ways of rendering this term on
the other hand in accordance with nature
it's a little bit too easy in some
respects right because we all know what
nature is but we might not have the same
idea that the Stoics themselves had of
nature so we want to take a look at both
of these I'm going to go through a
little bit of history first let's start
with the term that we're all familiar
with nature right and this notion of
being in accordance with nature in
harmony with nature it's not unique to
the Stoics as a matter of fact it plays
a central role in pretty much all of the
virtue ethics of the ancient world you
even see it popping up outside of the
Western sphere in other places as well
we do know that Zeno himself the founder
of stoicism wrote a work on life
according to nature and a on choice or
on human nature so it's a
fortunate that we've lost those we also
know that this doctrine of what is in
accordance with nature was discussed in
considerable detail how do we know that
well you know we've got these sources to
draw upon diogenes Laertes the lives of
the philosophers book seven is all about
the Stoics Cicero tells us quite a bit
Arius didymus is epitome of stoic ethics
also tells us quite a bit and they give
us not only detailed discussions of what
the Stoics meant by this but show us
that there was a ongoing development of
doctrine so that Zeno said one thing and
then clay anthias added something
precipitous added some more Diogenes
they added some more aunty Potter I
wouldn't go on and on and on the later
stoic thinkers the ones whose works we
actually possess Seneca with Sonia's
Rufus Epictetus Marcus Aurelius hero
please some of these in more fragmentary
ways than others they make constant
reference and applications and
occasionally explanations of what it
means to be in accordance with nature so
we're going to look at some of those by
the time that epictetus is talking about
this this is a long familiar stoic
doctrine and he uses a wide vocabulary
sometimes he talks about being in
accordance with nature or harmonizing
with nature sometimes he talks about
following nature or participating in
nature what about this other term proi
races so this is a term that again is
not original to epictetus or to stoicism
either it's used by a number of
different authors that you know the the
orators demosthenes and a Socrates use
it to talk about sort of choice of way
of life there's others as well who who
use it in speeches Plato mentions it at
one point
Aristotle uses it quite quite
extensively in his work and you could
say that in ancient times
Epictetus and Aristotle are the two
people who use
term the most then there's others who
who use it talking about similar things
Plutarch will bring it up in the lives
and in various moral treatises stoic
philosophers until the time of that
patatas don't appear to use it all that
much they they use it in it's sort of
lexical form so parole is before or in
place of right when we talk about
prioritization it's got that kind of
sense to it and then hey raices
literally is grabbing you know you're
grabbing on to something you're gripping
it and you're taking it so pro raíces is
is in some respect taking one thing
before another but you can think of it
as taking one thing in place of another
or prioritizing setting one thing above
another and in epictetus it's gonna take
on this much much wider extension as a
matter of fact you could say that
there's probably nobody in ancient times
who uses this term to mean as much as
epictetus does so what then does
Epictetus mean by this term throw a
racist that we've seen is is so
important in his work there's a number
of different ways that we can look at
this if we're you know examining it from
multiple perspectives that we're getting
from the enchiridion and the discourses
and i think one that could be helpful
right at the start is to think about it
in terms of what's in our power and
what's not in our power familiar to most
of you I'm sure is the dichotomy of
control it's also connected to this
notion of what's internal and external
right external things to acta are not in
our power not in our control okay
hey Mon write in Greek so what what is
actually within our power that tells us
what the scope of the prior raices is
what does epictetus tell us if you look
at enchiridion
desire and aversion right
our exes and ik leases this would also
include the emotions the path a choice
and refusal or may an up for mayor right
and also what we do with those choices
and refusals in terms of duties or the
cafe cone a sense that the actual
agreeing to things taking them on that's
within our power as well
assumptions Hoopa lapses opinions or
judgments dogma crema careening in in
Greek the preparation that we make is
also something that Epictetus says is in
our power and the purposes that we set
before us the place that you would want
to look after that would be booked for
chapter 11 and epictetus even uses this
term the lane which which means wheeling
or you know choosing and another key
thing that's encompassed by this what is
in our power is the use or dealing with
the crisis and Greek of externals of
appearances all those sorts of things
those fall within our power our control
they are our business they're up to us
that means that they fall within the
scope of the pro I races and the earlier
Stoics also wrote quite a bit about the
good and bad being virtue and vice that
you know lying within our power you can
read that into Epictetus he doesn't talk
as often about virtue and vice as others
but epictetus tells us over and over and
over again that the good and the bad lie
within the scope of the prior ASIS so
what is good for us what is bad for us
that is something that is up to us and
he tells us over and over again what we
ought to do so he says when we encounter
appearances or other matters that you
know seem to be an issue for us we apply
a rule is it outside of the province of
moral purpose or pro racists or is it
inside and then we can say not only is
the pro a racist this domain of things
that we have some control over some
saying it's also a kind of unity it's a
unity within the person themselves it's
what you are
and so for epictetus he says that it's
the very core of the the human being
another way of understanding this is its
the hegemony cone
it's the ruling part of you so he says
at one point in book 3
you are not flesh not hair but moral
purpose if you get that beautiful you
will be beautiful so this this faculty
that we have for choosing for selecting
for committing ourselves there's also
what we can call a reflexivity to pry
races he says that not even Zeus can
hinder it only only we can he says
nothing outside of the sphere of prior
ASIS or moral purpose can hamper or
injure it it alone
can hamper injure itself at one point he
this is in book 1 in chapter 17 he says
that Pro racists compelled for a racist
so how did it do so through what it
chose to think about this is probably
starting to gel in a lot of your minds
at this point prior Asus is not only
this reflexive that it works upon itself
this reflexive faculty it's also the
locus of our freedom what freedom we
actually do possess we use our freedom
to determine what our freedom is going
to mean what we're going to do with it
and so how does this Pro race this act
upon itself or determine itself well
partly through cognitive means partly
through what we choose to think about
how we choose to think about things do
we for example think about ourselves as
having been insulted or do we realize as
epictetus tells us that the insult
really lies in our judgment and not in
the person doing the insulting we also
do it through
practical reshaping of desire and
aversion of choice and refusal the first
tutto boy or fields of philosophy
according to Epictetus right we do it
through the creation and destruction and
the weakening and strengthening of
habits the redirection of the habits
that we have and we also do it by
continual attention to the choices that
have to be made now one of those key
choices is exactly what we're talking
about here do we choose to focus on what
it was that we wanted in the situation
or do we choose to focus on keeping our
pro races in accordance with nature
that's a central question for the pro
races okay then so then what does it
mean to be in accordance with nature
when it comes to stomache philosophy and
the prior races one key idea and this is
there from the very start is being part
of this larger whole that is the cosmos
but we can also think of it not only as
you know the entire universe we might
think about it as our particular
community or we might you know zero in a
little bit closer this is almost like
taking Heracles circles and and Heracles
wants us to bring the outside in maybe
we should concentrate on the inside a
bit think about our closed circles of
friends and families and you know extend
it a bit to co-workers or fellow
citizens of a particular place we're
part of something else
we're not the totality ourselves that
we're tempted to think we are we're not
the center of the universe we are a part
of it
Epictetus says this Marcus brings this
home even more in in his own works so
accepting our our fate accepting things
as they turn out to be physical
processes which are vulnerable to break
up and things like that that's part of
being in accordance with nature if I
expect
that I'm going to live in this body
forever or even that this shirt is gonna
survive forever I'm really setting
myself up for a lot of problems and so
to be in accordance with nature means to
see things as they genuinely are Seneca
says something kind of belong these
lines when he says that nature wishes
our laws to be identical with her own
what else does it mean to be in
accordance with nature here's where
there was a very interesting difference
Klee Anthes thought that being in
accordance with nature meant being in
accordance with the totality of the
universe cruciferous insisted that it
not only meant that but also being in
accordance with human nature this is
where sometimes modern points of view
can lead us astray because we often
attribute they add things to human
nature we say oh you know somebody stole
from me well let's use the example the
bath house again right somebody's going
to splash water on you jostle you vilify
you and rob you right insult you and
steal your stuff take your towel take
your wallet whatever it happens to be we
often say oh that's human nature people
are just bad that's not the way the
Stoics saw that they would say that is
degenerate human nature as a matter of
fact
Epictetus uses all sorts of metaphors of
human beings who've been transformed or
allowed themselves to sink to the level
of animals whether it be you know sheep
pursuing pleasure birds and beasts of
prey who are angry all the time or other
things stupid asses as well really
pursuing human nature means a fully
developed human nature a social nature a
rational nature that's what we should be
in accordance with beyond that there are
some very specific injunctions about
what it means to be in accordance with
nature Missoni Asst Rufus Epictetus this
teacher gives us some examples of that
that we might not agree with like for
example he says being a farmer is and
the occupation most in accordance with
nature I'm not sure that that's
necessarily so but there are quite a few
things like this some of them are kind
of
culturally bound as well so epictetus
will suggest that gender roles need to
be acknowledged that's part of nature
and I would be in good stead because
I've gotten nice beard those of you who
are men out there who don't have beards
Epictetus wouldn't like that so much
some of that we might want to put aside
or we might want to rethink and we want
to focus on the general things what what
else can we say is in accordance with
nature Epictetus insists over and over
and over again using appearances or
impressions fantasy I in accordance with
nature is central what does that mean
that means not necessarily accepting
them at face value questioning them
seeing whether they really amount to
anything not giving a cent to them
immediately he also talks about using
external things in accordance with
nature he talks about excessive emotions
as being contrary to nature and this is
you know Raman stoic doctrine doesn't
mean by the way that we can't have
emotions but they should be in
accordance with reason they should be
rational one particularly interesting
example is natural affection Phyllis
Toria epictetus says that that is
something that is in accordance with
nature as well to feel affection towards
those who we are connected with let's
consider a very short list of examples
in order to stick to time for this this
presentation so I mentioned fill a story
dear familial affection there's a really
great discussion in the discourse is
where epictetus is talking with this
this guy who's a dad and he says how's a
family life treating you and the dad
says oh it's terrible my daughter got
sick and I was so affected by familial
affection I had to leave I couldn't be
in the same room as her because I was so
worried about her an epic Tina says wait
would you you you left her
you left your sick kid that's not
familial affection that's not actually
in accordance with nature whatever
you're feeling buddy that was something
else the people who stuck around like
you know your wife and the nurse
they were actually acting naturally you
weren't acting naturally at all another
great example is in book three of the
discourses Epictetus talks about news
and he says that news on any subject
never falls within the sphere of the
perot races so it's never actually good
or bad news news can't be in accordance
of nature and not in accordance with
nature but you can keep your prior ASIS
your faculty of choice or moral purpose
in accordance with nature by not like
chasing after the news by not giving
into it by not giving it too much
importance another you know prime
example is the bath house that we are
just discussing when you go to the
public swimming pool you can either keep
your your prior ASIS in accordance with
nature by adjusting to things as they
are and reminding yourself that keeping
your cool is what's really important to
you not that you get to have I don't
know the best place and the hot tub or
that you know no kids run around
screaming or anything like that or there
isn't a slippery place you know because
people left water or anything like that
that's that's going to happen people are
gonna play their music people are gonna
scream people are going to interrupt
whatever activities you're engaged with
if you're doing laps somebody will get
in your way you have a choice though
about what you do to keep your Faculty
of choice your prior ASIS in accordance
with nature so let's talk a little bit
more about some of the other things that
he has to say about this
choosing rightly this is a really
central thing we're not only choosing
how we're reacting to things we're
choosing whether we value prior ASIS
this central part of ourselves more than
these other external things so it's not
just a choice between two alternatives
it's a choice about how we commit or
prioritize he tells us that we should
transfer our judgments that lie within
the province of morale
purpose and then will be steadfast no
matter what happens he says that
honoring anything outside of the scope
of moral purpose destroys it or wrecks
it so we want to be careful with what we
do with our prior ASIS
a little bit later in the enchiridion
when he's talking about the ruling
faculty says we ought to be careful like
somebody who's trying not to step on a
nail that we don't damage our ruling
faculty we have to keep this in mind and
that's an important technique every
situation that we go into the stakes are
higher than they first appear every time
were posed with a chance to make things
better for ourselves or to make things
worse and that's up to us a lot of this
has to do with what Epictetus calls
right you know use or proper use crisis
dealing with things he says that we
ought to be we should be cautious or
exert caution towards the things that
are within the scope of the prior ASUS
but be confident towards the outside
there's a really wonderful discussion of
this in book 2 chapter 1 we also have
this great metaphor of playing the game
the game the ball game that Socrates did
when it comes to the right use of
external things and rightly using
appearances we mentioned this a little
bit earlier that means not immediately
accenting to them assessing them
employing and developing criteria for
for you know determining what's really
going on another really key thing I
think that that
Epictetus drives home perhaps more than
any of the other stoic authors that we
have is how important roles and duties
are roles as he says reveal to us what
our duties are sometimes even the mere
word father son child coworker spouse
they tell us how we ought to be behaving
and to do those things is to to be in
accordance with nature to do so
willingly is to have our prior ASIS in
accordance with nature we have general
and individual standards to
what it is he also talks about
maintaining the person within you the
person of good character this comes up
in the context of Epictetus telling
somebody who is caught in adultery buddy
there's nothing I can do with you you're
damaged goods you need to get the hell
out here now that may be a bit harsh
right we might want to have some some
possibility of redemption for such a
person but Epictetus thinks that when we
choose the wrong things again we're not
just choosing those individual options
we are choosing something that bears
upon our moral character bears upon the
core of who we are
so these are some some important things
to keep in mind the last thing that I'll
say I think epictetus also stresses and
this is quite important especially for
us today in the present spread out all
across the world that we also look for
genuine friends he's got a very in a
wonderful chapter on friendship and book
two of the discourses and he talks about
genuine friends are those who see the
prior ASIS and keeping prior ASIS in
accordance with nature as the good so if
we share in that regardless of you know
what other circumstances we run into
we're going to have a lasting genuine
friendship that will allow us to support
what we're doing very often stoicism is
presented as like the lone person
against the world but I don't think that
actually matches the way that Epictetus
and earlier Stoics portrayed the stoic
life which is a social life a life lived
in community with others so those are
some some ideas about what it means to
have your prior ASIS in accordance with
nature hopefully this has been
thought-provoking I look forward to your
questions I'll just mention that I do
also have if you want to go a little bit
further into this two videos that all
send links to that might be useful for
you one is from the Midwest seminar in
ancient and medieval philosophy and it's
specifically on prior Asus and epictetus
the others a lecture that I gave at the
Center for Ethics and entrepreneurship
about what in accordance with nature
means for the stoic so if you want
additional stuff those would be good to
take a look at but I'll be happy to
answer your questions here over the next
half an hour or so